[Music]
we are making music with one of the most
talented people I've ever met named
Jacob Collier in the music world
Jacob's huge you know and and so in some
ways for him to get to work with all
these musicians the best thing
[Music]
and we were able to get him to come to
MIT and kind of do a week-long residency
[Applause]
mi t--'s visiting artists program is
trying to bring great artists in
substantive contact with our students
it's all about music education
experiences I wanted them to feel the
sparks of Jacob's creativity firsthand
and I wanted them to go beyond that to
get inside his music and to be able to
make it their own
but this kind of thing is all you really
need is like
[Music]
you could even find like a I mean I do
your anything but you could find a rift
thing that's just kind of like I just
like because I guess the guitar is like
basically a drummer it's supposed to be
a halt in strim he creates a really
great atmosphere for working with people
and bringing the best out of them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Megan amazing it's a creative
environment that really feeds me their
minds our officers have shark you know
and it's not even necessarily musically
sharp in the foreground but these guys
think about stuff there's this gig on
Saturday that if you don't have tickets
to I believe there's a waiting list but
you should come it's gonna be so crazy
200 musicians on the stage I'm
performing with Jacob Collier which is
amazing
[Music]
when I listen to his music he liked
since Joseph of my purse - Peschel II
hide away like that's my favorite song
[Music]
a sense of peace sense of calm and
something making sense
[Music]
when I started listening to the music I
realized this was a lot more complicated
than most arranging projects
[Music]
as a music nerd it's a beautiful-looking
score to me because there's all these
things that didn't appear like they
should be there from the beginning and
they start to show up
[Music]
his music is in many ways like classical
music which is that so much of it is
specified you know that
it's pretty moving for some people a
hideaway especially there are certain
points on the music word it's pretty
overwhelming
so like the call so he states the melody
he sings the melody it's all very tonal
and pretty and like a pop song and then
we get to the bridge and suddenly he
throws us for a loop yeah
[Music]
like uh never
[Music]
in place there are
[Music]
in my
the drummer has one of the hardest
things of all he's got to play the fives
on the cymbal but still maintain the
slow forward with his foot
[Music]
my heart
[Music]
in the second verse he adds this layer
of fives so
and it's made more complex by the fact
that the 5s are grouped in fours and
threes and sixes
[Music]
[Music]
it's you know you don't hear the math of
it when you're listening to the song you
just suddenly become unmoored than this
kind of dreamlike state and yet you
still hear the slow pulse from the
original part of the song he's kind of
playing with this notion of you the
listener thinking you know where you are
and he'll throw something at you that on
more is it but without completely
divorcing you from the structure that
you knew before
[Music]
[Music]
it's just it's a revelation it's amazing
and all of this is happening you know in
what at the beginning seemed to be a
simple four chord pop song
[Music]
this is kind of what our lives are like
is that we try to reduce them so that we
can get through the day but this stuff
going on that if we just pay attention
to it is beautiful inspiring frightening
and he's kind of encapsulating all of
this in in a five or six minute song
that appears to be a pop ballad at the
beginning
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
let me
[Music]
it was just like everything I had ever
wanted to hear in music because it's so
intricate in detail but it's purposeful
it like he has a purpose for everything
he does every note he hits every weird
beat that he plays
[Music]
what my mom did is recognized that I had
some kind of weird brain that was very
thirsty and very inventive and quite
emotionally mature and presented lots of
different things to me like this is bark
this is Stravinsky this is Bartok
interpreting this is Earth when in
father's Bobby McFerrin this is sting
those are like a lot of my heroes
growing up um and I and I wasn't told to
do anything with them I was just told to
enjoy them she used to do things like
turn on the vacuum cleaner always be
telling you hey the Hoover and plug it
into a sage a cabal no does that feel
like in someone I'm 2 2 years old
like gee so yeah Sergey really the
biggest gift I was given as a child was
a space and the affirmation to create in
it I was never ever told to practice
ever
it was never taught to practice and
people don't believe that no way you
know where's the discipline it's not a
thing and and and it's funny because
it's true but people have an idea of how
to learn and how to teach that I think
is horrific ly out of date
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I like going to at the beginning of for
Django the first thing you hear is the
strings come in and it's like the
announcing of the new song yeah so I
call it the change your texture for that
that's cool do you want to do those
edits you can plug in the speakers and
do those ads I'd love that
yeah can we look at a microphone yeah
[Music]
I saw one of his videos on YouTube and I
thought oh my gosh this guy's amazing
he's got this great sense of aesthetics
and editing skills and mixing and all
these things and I like to build music
tech stuff and so I sent him a Facebook
message saying I'm in MIT I make stuff
have you any ideas of stuff you'd like
to make I said oh well yes I have I've
always dreamed of singing harmony on the
spot gonna be a bit essentially
improvise a choir a harmonizer takes
whatever you're singing and there's a
keyboard and you can play different
notes and the notes that you play are
transformed so that what you sing is
spread across lots and lots of notes
basically multiplies his voice and
stacks
[Applause]
[Music]
because this is like wood Windell
insects those sounds go together don't
they yeah I'm gonna be creating this
kind of improvised harmonic more
spontaneous technological musical
compound piece where I can send the
musicians information during the
performance via maybe iPad screens or
something like this why say you play
these notes now and they play an expose
up and slows down and then I can fill in
the gaps and it's like a big
conversation and this is one of the main
pieces of work that will be done between
now and December I think one stage you
well you need one laptop that'll be the
MIDI input okay and that'll have a
keyboard
[Music]
we each open up a web page on our phone
and there's a staff so he's picking all
of these different notes chords rhythms
everything for every different
instrument and we're playing them as
they come up on our screen it's allowing
Jacob to literally play the band in real
time
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a scientist I'm an engineer too so I
like to tinker I like to explore things
and one of my best laboratories is is
with music so I think if anything Jacob
has made us into bolder risk more
risk-taking experimentalists alone
perhaps more about how it's best not to
learn and not to teach then how to learn
how to teach don't keep people all the
answers to things if you give people all
the answers then they are the subject to
your criteria but if you give them all
the questions and clues then they find
their own answers and actually the
process of finding an answer is almost
all of learning so I think teachers have
a responsibility to trust their students
to find not only answers but their own
answers that might be different from the
teachers answers especially comes
sunlight jazz which is so vague and so
expressive and personal
[Applause]
[Applause]
I had an idea for like for the section
whether it goes eating yeah I could be
them the rhythm what stage of the
process do you write the lyrics to the
song
it depends sometimes it's the first
thing that I write I write a lot I write
I have a thought but it's filled with
words really dense imagery like really
interesting dense imagery I want to come
try lyrics I try and write as little of
it as I can because the music is already
complex and I need to allow people to
find their own meanings in the words
like this on her Django it's just a
number of seven syllable lines everybody
near and far come together as you are
and to the ocean to the sky seeing that
cosmic lullaby that could mean lots of
different things that could be life and
death it could mean a simple song of
your mother's you see if we go to sleep
it could mean the actual universe like
velocity for things
[Music]
I'd rather bright words they invite
people to understand the rather than
rejected my understanding or to other
people
[Music]
every fall
[Music]
come together
[Music]
- yo Shinto
Cigna calls
see
we go John
[Music]
sing your pleasure sing your pain
[Music]
have to
the ancients ride
[Music]
when the good days buzzing by
[Music]
when those dog loves bring it down
your hand up the sky
[Music]
as the words round at around around
the tears fall down
see
you wish to be
[Applause]
[Music]
oh stop I was crazy dude
[Music]
spark joy
[Music]
breakdown fall
[Music]
the jaw voices from your heart
[Music]
and every night through the darkness to
the line like us because we shot crime
she didn't tell you
the winter comes the spring it don't
have to baby
[Music]
Sooni
[Music]
stop
[Music]
[Applause]
yes sir
[Music]
first nothing
[Music]
things you know
[Music]
probably busy this whole week but if you
ever find like an hour and you want to
go grab a fight anyway yeah yeah yeah
fantastic are you gonna be your Saturday
I just find me up to them so I'll be
hanging out all right Sheila I really
feel like MIT is a sort of second home
in some ways I've always very much felt
some kind of kinship with this kind of
idea of celebrating the introvert MIT
it's a sort of sublime understanding of
the people who think in words first I
would count myself in amongst a group of
people so I'd like to celebrate that
idea I think I'm being at MIT
consistently reminds me how wonderful it
is when people think beyond this level
and up and down into the other realms of
things so I like to sort of say thank
you to MIT as a concept
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if the goose thing and the basically
[Music]
it's cool right
it's like it's more cool than two to two
because they have a gravity that goes
towards the same place but they don't
have a unison line let's try to figure
this is a GU that's hard to nail finish
the groove on their on their on the
record and it's like it like a little
groove so it's it's less of a shuffle
and it's like halfway between a shuffle
and a normal groove so this is straight
and then this is true it's like coffee
bean it's less about putting the hi-hat
later it's more like bringing the snare
earlier if I see if I play and then you
guys can join in
maybe that's so good in the field
[Music]
I do have a goal they don't get it very
carefully and deliberately swings it in
certain ways and modulates the time and
pulls and pushes in a way that just gets
this like really visceral groove where
you just like get into it so much
that little bit of extra effort to you
know change it makes such a difference
and that's such a a Jacob kind of
construct isn't that extra bit of
intention that just you know even just a
tiny little breath I'm a tiny little
extra note or something that doesn't
quite you know fit in what the rules say
they're supposed to do we had you guys
split into two sections of what you sing
at different things put your hand in the
air if you people need to sing along
with in this next song with me and by
that I mean everybody raise your hand
this is a song called Savior
it's the lawsuit of the night thank you
so so much for coming this must be what
Quincy Jones felt when he first
encountered Stevie Wonder or Michael
Jackson but here's someone who has
really really deep musical resources is
marshaling this at a young age he has
phenomenal performance skills arranging
skills composition skills it's just
incredible that all this exists in a
single person
[Music]
[Music]
she wants to touch down below and up
[Applause]
[Music]
the one frame
Oh
[Music]
Oh
anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the way he performs is enthralling I
can't even begin to imagine his
potential I mean he's only what 22 I
just think all of us are so incredibly
lucky
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's one of those once-in-a-lifetime
kind of people that changes the way you
look at this
[Music]
you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's really inspiring it makes me think
that there's real divinity in the world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
take these broken wings I know you're
only wait [ __ ] it's normal to her for
this mama - but some girls learn se
lunacy let's see oh yeah oh you waiting
for this mom on TV mama to be free